Glutamat ist unbedenklich?
Aber warum hört man dann immer
wieder, man soll es vermeiden?
Weil ...
Boah, das ist eine wirklich
seltsame Geschichte.
Holt euch einen Tee, macht es euch
gemütlich, wir steigen durch.
(Dynamische Musik, Knall)
Wie immer vorab ein paar Basics.
Das ist Glutamat.
Ein farbloses Salz,
das man zum Kochen einsetzen kann.
Es schmeckt pur
nach gar nicht mal so viel.
Schon so ein bisschen herzhaft,
aber eher wie so ...
fade Hühnerbrühe.
Aber eins nach dem Anderen.
Glutamat ist das Salz
der Glutaminsäure.
Eine der 20 kanonischen Aminosäuren,
aus denen alle unsere Proteine
aufgebaut sind.
Glutaminsäure
beziehungsweise Glutamat
kommt in vielen Lebensmitteln
natürlicherweise vor
und wird auch von unserem Körper
hergestellt.
Das heißt, für menschenfressende
Tiere und für Kannibalen
sind auch wir glutamathaltige
Lebensmittel.
In dieser reinen Form
wurde Glutamat erstmals 1908
von dem japanischen Chemiker
Kikunae Ikeda aus Algen isoliert.
Er war nämlich auf der Suche
nach einem ganz besonderen Geschmack.
Während eines Forschungsaufenthaltes
in Leipzig stellte Ikeda fest,
dass manche deutsche Lebensmittel -
Tomaten, Spargel, Käse, Fleisch -
eine ganz besondere Würze hatten.
Besondere Würze,
deutsche Lebensmittel ...
Sicher, dass das richtig ist?
Ikeda identifizierte
diesen besonderen Geschmack
nicht nur in gewissen deutschen
Speisen,
sondern erkannte ihn auch in Japan
wieder, zum Beispiel in Dashi.
Das ist eine kräftige Brühe, tradi-
tionell mit Konbu-Algen zubereitet.
Dieser charakteristisch-herzhafte
Geschmack,
der in Fleisch, getrockneten Tomaten,
Parmesan oder Dashi steckt,
nennt sich Umami.
Umami ist neben süß, salzig,
sauer und bitter
die fünfte Geschmacksrichtung
und heißt auf Japanisch
soviel wie Köstlichkeit.
Kurze Ergänzung: Ich meine damit
die Hauptgeschmacksrichtungen,
die wir wirklich mit den Haupt-
rezeptoren auf der Zunge wahrnehmen.
Darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich
ganz viele verschiedene Aromen,
die wir aber hauptsächlich
durch die Nase aufnehmen.
Wikipedia beschreibt Umami als
fleischig, würzig, wohlschmeckend.
Da man Umami schwieriger beschreiben
und identifizieren kann
als andere Geschmacksrichtungen,
war man sich lange nicht sicher,
ob man Umami tatsächlich als eigenen
Geschmack klassifizieren sollte.
Und obwohl man das inzwischen macht,
wird immer noch über diese
Klassifizierung diskutiert.
Aber tatsächlich sitzen auf unserer
Zunge Umami-Rezeptoren.
Einige Substanzen - Aspartat,
Inosinat, Guanylat und Glutamat -
aktivieren diese Umami-Rezeptoren.
Genau wie Natriumchlorid unsere
salzig-Rezeptoren aktiviert,
oder Saccharose
unsere süß-Rezeptoren.
Nur ist der pure Umami-Geschmack
im Gegensatz zu salzig oder süß
erstaunlich mild.
Und erst in Kombination
mit anderen Aromen
kommt die geschmacksverstärkende
Wirkung zustande.
In dieser Studie
gab man Studienteilnehmern
eine Glutamat-Inosinat-Lösung
zu trinken -
also quasi Wasser
mit purem Umami-Geschmack -
und ließ sie gleichzeitig
ein Gemüsearoma schnüffeln.
Der Umami-Geschmack
oder das Gemüsearoma alleine
wurden jeweils
als nicht so geil bewertet.
Aber in Kombination ergab sich
ein angenehmeres Geschmackserlebnis.
Und sogar in Hirnscans
konnte man Ähnliches beobachten.
Bei der Kombi aus Umami-Drink
und Gemüsearoma
war die Hirnaktivität stärker als
die Summe der beiden Einzelgaben.
Speaking of Hirn - Glutamat
ist auch ein Neurotransmitter.
Also eines der Moleküle, mit denen
Hirnzellen miteinander kommunizieren.
Sidenote für alle,
die sich Sorgen machen,
dass Glutamat die Neurochemie
durcheinanderbringen könnte:
Glutamat, das wir über das Essen
zu uns nehmen,
kommt nicht so ohne Weiteres ins
Gehirn. Wegen der Blut-Hirn-Schranke.
Einer Barriere zwischen
Zentralnervensystem und Blutbahn,
die nur bestimmte Stoffe durchlässt.
1885 zeigte Paul Ehrlich,
dass ein blauer Farbstoff,
der in die Blutbahn eines
toten Tieres injiziert wurde,
den ganzen Körper blau färbte,
außer das Gehirn.
Später demonstrierte ein Student
Ehrlichs das Gegenteil,
nämlich, dass das Blaufärben
von Gehirnen toter Tiere
nicht zu einer Färbung
des restlichen Körpers führte.
Das heißt, Glutamat ist nicht
grundsätzlich schädlich,
sondern ein dem Körper
vertrauter Stoff.
Aber: Könnte vielleicht
wie bei Zucker oder Salz
die Dosis das Gift machen?
Das könnte sein.
Aber dazu kommen wir gleich noch.
Zurück zu Ikeda.
1909 brachte er Glutamat in Form
seines Natriumsalzes auf den Markt.
Natriumglutamat, auf Englisch
Monosodium Glutamate, kurz MSG.
MSG brachte puren Umami-Geschmack
ins Gewürzregal vieler Küchen.
Sidenote: Etwa zur selben Zeit
brachte der Schweizer Julius Maggi
Brühpulver und Suppenwürfel
auf den europäischen Markt.
Sorry für diese Sidenote-Inception,
aber ich musste hier
noch mal kurz rein,
denn Jens hat mich drauf hingewiesen,
dass Julius Maggi Italiener ist
und "Madschi" gesprochen wird.
Das Klugscheißer-Wissen
wollte ich euch nicht vorenthalten.
Damals war Maggi noch nicht bewusst,
dass das gewisse Etwas
in Hühner- oder Gemüsebrühe
Umami-Geschmack ist.
Der unter anderem durch das
in den Zutaten
natürlich enthaltene Glutamat
entsteht.
Dazu zählen Sachen wie "Würze"
aus Weizen
oder anderen pflanzlichen Rohstoffen,
oder auch Hefeextrakt,
das auch reich an Glutamat
und damit reich
an Umami-Geschmack ist.
Oder man kann natürlich auch einfach
bisschen reines Glutamat hinzufügen,
wie es etwa bei der beliebten
Maggi-Würze getan wird.
Was? Deutschlands geliebtes Maggi
enthält Glutamat?
(Frau, off:) Das Drama
kannst du dir sparen.
Alle kennen den Videotitel.
- Ja, stimmt.
Also: Es fing alles an
mit einer Art Leserbrief
in einer medizinischen
Fachzeitschrift.
Der vielleicht aber auch nur
eine Art Trollpost war.
Passt auf.
1968 wurde in dem renommierten
"New England Journal of Medicine",
in dem in erster Linie medizinische
Studien veröffentlicht werden,
dieser "letter to the editor"
abgedruckt.
Ein chinesisch-amerikanischer Arzt
namens Robert Ho Man Kwok
beschrieb, dass er gewisse Symptome
bei sich selbst feststellte,
immer, nachdem er bei einem
chinesischen Restaurant war.
Taubheitsgefühl im Nacken, das
Richtung Arme und Rücken weiterläuft,
allgemeine Schwäche,
Müdigkeit und Herzklopfen.
Er spekuliert über mögliche Auslöser,
unter anderem Glutamat.
Und ob seine Kollegen nicht Lust
hätten das näher zu erforschen,
er würde auch mitmachen.
"Chinese Restaurant Syndrome"
wurde das Ganze betitelt.
Mehrere Mediziner antworteten
ihrerseits in letters to the editor,
dass es ihnen ähnlich ginge.
Dass auch sie nach dem Besuch
eines chinesischen Restaurants
gewisse Symptome
bei sich feststellten,
und bald berichtete
die "New York Times"
vom Chinese Restaurant Syndrome, das
Ärzte anscheinend entdeckt hätten.
Es folgten eine Reihe
wissenschaftlicher Studien,
die zu verschiedenen Befürchtungen
im Zusammenhang mit Glutamat führten.
Kopfschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen,
Übelkeit, Übergewicht,
Risiko für Alzheimer oder Parkinson
und Vieles mehr.
Aber: Viele dieser Studien
waren zum Beispiel Tierversuche,
in denen Glutamat
in extrem hohen Dosen
direkt in den Bauch injiziert wurde.
Das hat mit Glutamat,
wie man es in der Küche verwendet,
natürlich nicht mehr so viel zu tun.
Das Einzige,
was man hier sagen kann, ist:
Bitte nicht hochdosiert
Glutamat spritzen.
Oder es waren Studien mit Menschen,
die aber methodisch
für die Tonne waren.
Etwa, weil die Menschen
nur befragt wurden.
"Leiden Sie am Chinese Restaurant
Syndrome?" "Ja." "Alles klar."
Science.
Oder Studien,
die nicht verblindet waren.
Also wo Leute wussten, dass sie
Glutamat zu sich nahmen.
Und das soll ich jetzt essen, ja?
Wenn man weiß, dass man etwas
potenziell Schädliches zu sich nimmt,
kann es leicht
zum Noceboeffekt kommen.
Das ist der negative Bruder
vom Placeboeffekt,
wo allein die Erwartung
von Nebenwirkungen
zu Kopfschmerzen oder Bauchschmerzen
führen kann.
Und als sich dann mit der Zeit
methodisch saubere Studien häuften,
in denen zum Beispiel eine Testgruppe
eine Glutamattablette bekommt,
die Kontrollgruppe eine
Placebotablette, alles verblindet,
fand man keinen nennenswerten Effekt.
Und sogar Studien mit Menschen,
die selbst eine
Glutamatunverträglichkeit angaben,
ergaben durchwachsene und meist
nicht reproduzierbare Ergebnisse.
Ich hab euch mehr Details
zur Studienlage
zum Nachlesen in die
Videobeschreibung gepackt,
aber kurz gesagt: Angst vor Glutamat,
vor allem in den Mengen,
in denen es als Geschmacksverstärker
eingesetzt wird, ist unbegründet.
Moment. Heißt das, dass manche
versuchen, Glutamat zu vermeiden,
nur weil 1968 einige Ärzte Anekdoten
über Bauchschmerzen austauschten?
Ja, so kann man's sagen. Aber, Leute,
es ist noch nicht zu Ende.
Es ist noch nicht mal sicher, ob es
Robert Ho Man Kwok wirklich gab.
Passt auf.
Wie gesagt, das "New England Journal
of Medicine"
ist eine renommierte Fachzeitschrift.
Aber dieser correspondence-Teil,
in dem diese letters to the editor
abgedruckt wurden,
war damals ... ja, fast schon wie
eine Art Reddit-Bord für Mediziner.
Vieles von dem,
was da veröffentlicht wurde,
wurde mit einem Augenzwinkern
geschrieben.
Es gab zum Beispiel
fast schon eine Art Tradition,
Fake-Symptome zu erfinden oder
zu überspitzen, zu übertreiben,
um sich darüber zu amüsieren.
Fragt mich nicht, Leute.
Medizinerhumor in den 60ern?
So, und jetzt kommt der Knaller.
Man findet ein paar Artikel,
zum Beispiel diesen hier,
die berichten, dass Dr. Ho Man Kwok
nur eine Erfindung war,
hinter der in Wirklichkeit
ein Dr. Howard Steel steckte.
Nach eigenen Angaben hatte Steel den
Brief damals als Witz geschrieben,
und sei davon ausgegangen,
dass es allen klar sein würde,
dass es einer dieser witzigen -
"witzigen" - Beiträge war.
Der Name Ho Man Kwok soll ein Wort-
spiel für human crock gewesen sein.
Anscheinend gibt es den Ausdruck als
Abkürzung für "human crock of shit",
was dann soviel heißt
wie "piece of shit".
Ach! Jedenfalls sollte damit
offensichtlich sein,
dass das Ganze
nicht ernst gemeint war.
Man findet sogar
einige Antwortbriefe,
die dieses Wortspiel mit Crock
erkannt und aufgenommen haben.
Wobei man jetzt auch sagen muss: Ob
dieser Fake nun wirklich echt ist ...
ist auch nicht sicher.
Das beruht alles auf den Aussagen
von Howard Steel.
Abgesehen davon gibt es jetzt im
Nachhinein keine weiteren Belege.
Außerdem behauptet Steel, er erfand
nicht nur den Namen Ho Man Kwok,
sondern auch dessen Institut,
die National Biomedical Research
Foundation Silver Spring, Maryland.
Doch die existiere gar nicht.
Sagt Steel.
Aber es gibt zumindest
dieses Fachbuch über Proteine,
und siehe da: National
Biomedical Research Foundation
in Silver Spring, Maryland.
Leute, ich hab euch gesagt,
es ist eine seltsame Geschichte.
Aber ob real fake oder fake fake
ist ja auch eigentlich egal,
denn diese Briefe waren definitiv
kein fachlicher Austausch
auf Basis wissenschaftlicher Evidenz.
Sondern teilweise, ja,
einfach nur Herumgetrolle.
Nur von außen wurde das Ganze
natürlich als Korrespondenz
zwischen medizinischen Fachleuten
wahrgenommen.
Medienberichte wie die der "New York
Times" fielen in der Öffentlichkeit
schnell auf einen fruchtbaren Boden
von allgemeinem antiasiatischen
Rassismus.
Chinesisches Essen zum Beispiel
wurde ohnehin oft
als eklig oder unsauber dargestellt.
Wäh, die essen Ratten und Hunde.
Okay, aber dann zu Mäckes ... egal.
Bestimmt waren auch einige der
Mediziner, die mit ihren Briefen
das ganze Debakel angestoßen hatten,
von diesen Vorurteilen nicht befreit.
Und als dann noch Ergebnisse
aus fragwürdigen Glutamatstudien
die Runde machten,
war die Angst irgendwann etabliert.
Und was passiert dann?
Dann fangen natürlich
Lebensmittelhersteller
und Restaurants an, sich
"No MSG" oder "Ohne Glutamat"
auf die Fahne zu schreiben, und was
die Kunden dann denken, ist klar:
Glutamat muss ja schlecht sein,
sonst würden sie nicht damit werben.
Dabei kann Glutamat in manchen Fällen
nicht nur nicht schlecht sein,
sondern vielleicht sogar gut.
Es geht ja nicht darum, sich
grammweise Glutamat reinzuschaufeln,
sondern um den Einsatz als Gewürz.
Genau wie Salz oder Zucker.
Sidenote: Zucker ist, denke ich,
ein wichtiges Gewürz
für herzhaftes Essen,
auch in der asiatischen Küche.
Nun gibt es aber die Befürchtung, die
momentan auch noch untersucht wird,
dass Glutamat mit Übergewicht
zusammenhängen könnte.
Die Überlegung dahinter
lässt sich runterbrechen auf:
Wenn mir etwas
besonders gut schmeckt -
und Glutamat macht ja Essen
schmackhafter -
dann esse ich davon vielleicht mehr
als ich sollte.
Das ist auch eine mögliche Erklärung
für Bauchschmerzen nach dem Essen.
Glutamat wird oft in Fertigprodukten
eingesetzt
oder in ungesunden Snacks wie Chips,
oft in Form von Hefeextrakt.
Das heißt, an der Faustregel,
Glutamat vermeiden,
um sich gesünder zu ernähren,
ist schon was dran.
Nur liegt es nicht
am Glutamat an sich,
sondern eher an den Lebensmitteln,
denen Glutamat zugesetzt wird.
Aber da Glutamat auch frisches Gemüse
schmackhafter machen kann,
ist es ja eine super Hilfe,
um mehr Gemüse zu essen.
Und auch bei veganen
Fleischersatzprodukten
sind Umami-Substanzen wie Glutamat,
Hefeextrakt oder Ähnliches
natürlich essenziell für den Umami-
fleischartigen herzhaften Geschmack.
Manche würden vielleicht gerne
weniger Fleisch essen,
strugglen aber damit,
weil ihnen Fleisch so gut schmeckt.
Da kann man ja dankbar sein
für Umami-Food-Science,
dass Fleischersatzprodukte
immer besser werden
und so vielleicht auch das Weniger-
Fleisch-Essen erleichtern.
Umami gegen die Klimakrise!
Ich hab ja noch nie
mit Glutamat gekocht,
aber ich werde demnächst mal
experimentieren.
Wenn ihr das mitbekommen wollt,
folgt mir auf Instagram.
Apropos Klimakrise: Lars und ich
haben uns in den letzten Monaten
mit Kollegen vom WDR zusammengetan
und eine zweiteilige Doku
zum Thema Klimawandel gemacht.
Wir wollten nämlich
nicht immer nur sagen,
"Klimaforscher sind sich einig",
sondern wir wollten wirklich
nachvollziehbar machen,
worin genau sie sich einig sind.
Woher wissen sie das und wo gehen
Meinungen auch auseinander?
Dazu haben wir uns Technologien,
Innovationen angeschaut
um zu gucken: Was ist Hype,
was Rettung?
Ich finde, man kriegt nach dem Film
eine neue Sicht auf den Klimawandel.
Leider kriegen sie momentan noch
wenig Aufmerksamkeit,
alle interessieren sich nur
für Corona.
Aber wenn ihr ein bisschen Support
zu verschenken habt,
schaut vorbei, falls es euch gefällt,
lasst ein paar Kekse.
Teilt es gerne, darüber würde sich
das Team und ich auch riesig freuen.
Ansonsten sehen wir uns bei MaiLab in
zwei Wochen. Bis dahin bleibt sicher.